grand theft auto 5's next gen launch is
right around the corner if you're
looking at hopping back into the streets
of los santos or if you're thinking
about joining gta online for the first
time here's everything to know to
prepare for the march 15th launch
before we begin a reminder that gta 5
next gen is not a software update to the
current ps4 or xbox one version but
rather an entire re-release that you'll
need to buy for your playstation 5 or
xbox series x or s the ps4 and xbox one
versions have been the console home for
gta 5 for so long that this felt like it
was worth mentioning
[Music]
first and foremost let's talk about when
you can download gta 5. beginning march
8th you're able to purchase and pre-load
the next-gen version onto your ps5 or
xbox series x or s if you're planning to
transfer last gen data you can prepare
your account with the following steps
pause the game in story mode go to the
game tab then select upload save game
you'll only be able to upload one saved
file per platform so make sure it's the
latest save you have the save file you
upload will stay on the rockstar servers
for 90 days your gta online and the rest
of your rockstar social club content
like your cars progression properties
and clothing will carry over once you
launch the next gen version up for the
first time however if you purchase
rockstar money from say the playstation
or microsoft store that money will only
transfer over if you're on the same
platform from last gen to next chin
as mentioned in the rockstar blog post
gta nextgen will feature updated visuals
and quality of life updates let's get
into what you can expect beginning with
game modes gta 5 will launch with three
performance fidelity and performance ray
tracing performance mode will feature a
targeted 60 frames per second and
display an upscaled 4k image on ps5 and
xbox series x
if you're playing on a series s the
performance modes display will offer a
1080p resolution instead next is
fidelity mode this mode will run gta 5
at 30 frames per second like before but
add a native 4k display if you're
playing on playstation 5 or series x the
series s will feature fidelity mode as
well but will offer an upscaled 4k
display instead of a native 4k last is
performance ray tracing mode this mode
is only available on playstation 5 and
series x consoles it's basically a
hybrid mode that supports ray tracing a
targeted 60fps and an upscaled 4k
display
okay let's take a moment to talk about
some other upcoming quality of life
features as well as other planned
updates
gta next gen will feature increased
population and vegetation around los
santos as well as improved lighting
effects motion blur anti-aliasing
updated water reflections and quote
highly detailed new explosions and fire
between you and me when they increased
the population count and gta definitive
trilogy i noticed every wrong move i
made got me into some trouble because
there was always a cop walking around
not minding his own business so since
this is happening to gta 5 next gen i
can safely say that the streets of los
santos are about to be crowded last but
not least playstation 5 owners will have
a selection of options for their dual
sense controllers this includes
vibrations reacting to varying weather
effects directional damage explosions
and more of those rough road surfaces
after an 8 year run on playstation 4 and
xbox one and one measly year of support
for playstation 3 users like me
gta online will also get the next-gen
treatment let's begin with career
builder this is a feature that allows
anyone to hop into gta online with a new
character and 4 million gta bucks to get
you going if you want to hop back into
gta online like me this is your chance
because that 4 million bucks easily gets
you started with a new car properties
weapons and of course more problems
[Music]
while this mode is tailored to new
players returning players can take
advantage of career builder and wipe the
slate clean with a brand new character
so if you want a clean start and a cool
4 mil it might be worth considering the
next gen refresh will also add an
updated gta online tutorial as well as a
new front end menu that will let you
jump straight into online mode instead
of waiting around for this screen to
give you the option once you're set up
you can hop back into the wonderful and
dangerous world of gta online and take
part in heists races and more also
coming to gta online is how's special
works this is an all new car meet update
that will bring the best in class
vehicle upgrades new classes of racing
using specially modified vehicles a
weekly rotation of how special works
time trials and a premium test ride
where you can get behind the wheel of
those newly modified vehicles for free
and you can also test drive these
specially modified vehicles with the
feature premium test ride there's a lot
to look forward to with gta 5 and
next-gen so if you've made it this far
let us know if you're planning on
jumping back in if you're enjoying gta
videos like this drop a like and
subscribe for more thanks for watching
[Music]
you